[Music]
[Applause]
what's a bigger disappointment in New
York the Yankees who are now in last
place or the Mets under 500 Chris Mad
Dog Russo joining us he brings you high
heat on MLB Network let me start there
Chris bigger disappointment in New York
the Yankees to the Mets that's very good
to be on Dan you know we love you I
would definitely say the Mets because
the Yankees have the excuse for judge
F-16 and 19 with Adam so as a result I
picked LA and Rondon didn't pitch and I
think that at the end of the day I still
think people think the Yankees will be
okay I think the Mets are colossal flop
I mean let's be honest they haven't
gotten great starting pitching
especially out of the big two of those
shows it was good yesterday but a little
late uh they're inconsistent offensively
there's seven or eight games out of uh
below 500 I remember about the Mets most
Met fans are jets fans so the Mets
season is over I mean the Jetstar camp
this week with Aaron Rodgers and they
play the Browns in the Hall of Fame game
nobody is going to care about the Mets
at all the next two and a half months I
mean all right there pay attention at
the deadline if they make some trades I
heard you're talking about that a few
minutes ago but the Mets season they're
not wanting obviously they're 30 Games
behind Atlanta and they're not going to
make the plays with the Wild Card the
Yankees could still easily make the
playoffs as a wild card so I think the
Mets active right now off last year
Verlander the owners got more money than
God they got a 360 million dollar
payroll they're much more disappointed
is this owner getting a hall pass Steve
Cohen with the Mets yes does he deserve
a hall pass I right now he does yeah
he's at least spending if I'm a Mets fan
he's trying which is what you want a
hundred percent plus the Grammy left but
the ground then hurts his arms so people
can't kill him about letting the Glam
walk because he's got a second Tommy
John he brought Verlander in most Med
fans didn't have a problem with that he
lost Diaz uh you know a lot of these uh
versatile role players the Kanas the
martes the third baseman having hit
nearly as well Alonzo's hitting 200 he
gets a pass I think the GM gets a little
brief and Epler I think Buck will get a
little grief but I do think the fact
that the owner is a blood of fresh air
hasn't gone off the deep end with moves
and moaning and cloning about the
manager and everything else at a 355
million dollar payroll he just bought
the team the owner gets the complete
pass on the other side of the coin I
think thank you fan cashman's been there
for 25 years whether he's done a great
job so so job he's been here 25 years
with success but that's a long time to
be a general manager of a team in New
York 25 years and they haven't been in
the World Series in 14 years and people
are done on Boone I mean Boone's been
there since 2018 and they have not been
to a World Series they fired the
previous manager who has been there
about the same amount of time and won a
World Series so that's some of the
issues with Boone I think people go down
on those two but as far as Cohen is
concerned Dan you know the New York fan
I think most Met fans after will Pond
likes Cohen as his owner what would be
bigger to the city the Jets winning the
Super Bowl or the Knicks winning the NBA
Finals yes
the Jets I mean uh the football is
bigger than basketball
um I understand that a lot of New York
fans like the football Giants and
there's no Nets fans so there's more of
a New York Knick fandom they they
dominate the market much more than say
the Jets do because of the Giants but I
think the Jets they've been basically
useless since 1969. Rogers is a huge
player football is a far bigger sport
um I don't think and plus the
expectation level I think there's an
expectation level with the jet band with
Rogers most people realize the Knicks
have gotten better but they're a second
round playoff team and so the they don't
expect them to win and they're not going
to win an NBA championship I think the
expectation level for the Jets is much
higher which then increases the juice if
they win so I think the Jets are a much
bigger story I think the Jets are the
biggest story in New York right now as
far as winning I think if the Jets win
it will be bigger than any other team
win it Giants Mets Rangers I think if
they met Jets win at all that's a huge
story in the fall in New York Chris Mad
Dog Russo host of Mad Dog Unleashed on
SiriusXM high heat on MLB Network you uh
Aaron Rodgers guy
uh yeah I love rogers's game I think
that um you know he hasn't been great in
the postseason he's coming off a so-so
year was not great against the Lions the
year before San Francisco uh he's good
to the media he gives you he comes on
he's not afraid to talk I think he
thinks he's smarter than everybody in
the room so I think that bothers some
people sometimes he thinks he's smarter
than you uh but you know he seems to
have embraced being a jet he seems to
understand a bit of the jet history now
he's been all over the place Ranger
games Nick games Taylor Swift he's
trying to got him he's trying to get
himself immersed in the New York culture
uh but I think that uh Chris Chris he
was stuck in Green Bay for 15 years he
needed to get out and do some things
socially uh Swift is not going to Lambo
uh so if a match standpoint I think that
uh he's done everything good since he's
been here he showed up at OTA is which
is helpful and a jet band is so psyched
to be relevant so psyched to be in a
post-season scenario and they should be
and with Wilson Garrett Wilson and with
obviously you know signing the defensive
lineman this week place the running back
comes back I mean they bring in Lazard
they they should be he's here they
brought in Hackett to help him they
should have a good year now the Jets
always have a black cloud so let's not
go crazy but the Jets should be what 11
and 6 12 and 5 right in the mix for a
division with Buffalo uh should be a
playoff team a lot of teams make the
postseason and then it's a crap shoot
burrow Mahomes who knows but they should
be a factor in 2025 I'd be shocked if
they're not they should have a good team
back to baseball John morosi from MLB
Network says the angels are now in a
listening mode with shoheiotani trade
inquiries
I don't know what that means you're in a
listener means nothing okay
right I mean what does that mean uh sure
the guy calls up and says I'll give you
my whole roster Forum uh you you know
you'd have to listen I don't think the
owners trading them I really don't the
angels are done we know that they're
finished uh but I I don't think that
owner who's been here forever if he
leads us a free agent and you put a 40
million dollar roll from the table and
he leaves you won't get destroyed if you
don't
um if you trade them you're gonna get
killed like for uh Frazee did with the
Red Sox back with Ruth uh what are you
gonna get for him anyway you know you
get a couple of prospects everybody who
brings him in knows he's just the rental
even if he goes to the Dodgers and you
don't want to trade him to La why would
you want to train them to the Dodgers I
mean you know they're 30 miles away the
Giants I don't think are going to spend
are going to trade for him nor do I
think Texas will so he not kidding the
Yankees got enough issues the Mets on in
the mix right now so I don't think the
uh you're gonna get enough back anyway
to make it worth your while I mean I I
know you get a couple of prospects back
but again with whom him only being maybe
available for a couple of months with
that franchise and I know the Dodgers I
know Texas I know the Giants I would be
really surprised if voltani is not an
angel after July 31st now I don't think
he's going to sign there yeah but I
would be surprised if they trade him I
really would I don't think it's a story
better for baseball if he stays or if
he's traded
uh traded because you want them in the
playoffs you know and he's not going to
stay there long term so he's not going
to be there next year so you want him
into postseason and baseball has some
issues with his postseason then it's
always up against football which is
tricky there you go games on FS1 you
know you can never find them you know
we've come we go through this all the
time because she got Tampa the twins you
know Milwaukee you know you you don't
have the Mets you don't have the Cubs
you know you may not have the Yankees so
I mean Red Sox probably not so you don't
have a lot of those big teams and you
may not have a lot on it so botania gets
traded to a big team and they make the
plus he's eyeballs from the set and they
need that so I think baseball if they
traded him to a team that's going to be
in the postseason I think that's good
for the game you need to see you need to
see old Tony in October you know
that's why he has to look around and go
what is Mike Trout's career other than
he's been in a playoff game and he's
he's gone to the Hall of Fame he's been
an MVP but that was nine years ago that
he was in a playoff for 10 years ago he
was in a playoff and Otani has to look
around going
I'm gonna get paid a lot of money
but nobody's gonna see me exactly right
and I don't want to hear about people
wondering going about shout because
shouts on two long-term contracts with
the angels he signed one three years ago
and bet silent the Dodgers he easily
could have played out the string and
gone to a team that's got pitching that
will win every year Phyllis and he
didn't he took the 420 million and
stayed with the angels so this idea that
we gotta have a pity party for trout oh
we'd ever see him in October what a
display so hold on now he could have
been in October he could have left the
Angels who haven't been as you said have
not been a huge factor for a long period
of time and he decided to stay so I
can't feel sorry for Trout's a lot in
life because he could have left oh Tony
I think Otani is you know at the end of
the day I think there's three teams I
think Seattle's sneaky I think they
could get him uh and next year I think
the Giants are a possibility and I think
the Dodgers I think those are the three
teams full-time at the end of the day I
don't think he's going to the east coast
Before I Let You Go
60 seconds to talk Wimbledon if you
would like oh yeah you know one of the
Glorious finals you're ever going to see
both players played great uh had Evan
flow to the match uh Al cares is going
to win 10 to 20 Majors easy in his
career
um you know uh Djokovic missed a
swinging volley there in that fifth set
tie break and that fifth set when he had
a break point at 1-1 but it was a win
for tennis Dan you know five hours back
and forth Djokovic is better when he's
got an opponent because then it's a
great
contrasted Styles and I think with the
bad weather in the Northeast yesterday
I'd be surprised if they didn't have
some people watching and it was good for
the sport and Al cares is something I
mean let's face it I mean he does it all
I mean as Djokovic said in his
post-match he said he's a combination of
Federer and and Nadal that's how good
alcarez is he's won two majors by the
time he's 20. he's gonna play 16 years
Djokovic is going to retire as soon as
who the hell is going to beat him he's
gonna win 20 major this guy is that good
so it was good for the sport loved it
fun to watch uh Chris uh heads up Mad
Dog Sports Radio on Sirius XM and uh Mad
Dog unleash that's uh three to seven
every day I believe it's still three are
you one through three to six oh you're
mailing it in you're only doing three
hours only doing three thank God uh and
and you're going to the Jersey Shore
uh bar A Bar Anticipation in New Jersey
what the hell are you doing in Jersey
well you know it's funny I did that show
at bar a way
way around 11. I would go you know
Friday in the summertime it's a big bar
it's about a block it's about three or
four blocks from the ocean in Belmar uh
it's loose right near Spring Lake and I
had a good time band South Side Johnny
and everything else and then I left fan
and I have not been
and I I mailed in my resignation from
the bar a on a Thursday night because I
didn't have a fax machine so I went to
bar a as I was at the church to mail in
my resignation and when I could when I
went to Serious uh you know 14 years ago
so I have not been back and serious
zimbare made a deal I'm gonna go August
fourth three to seven on a Friday
afternoon in three weeks so okay wait a
minute did you did you announce your
resignation the way Pat Riley did when
he didn't he fax in his resume to the
mix yes
yes
fan wanted to get that
immediately and in that letter I was not
allowed to go work at ESPN Radio
so in the resignation letter to get it
in I had to indicate and I was going to
go to sirius anyway I wasn't gonna that
I was not allowed to be on the air on
ESPN so they wanted that ASAP so that is
why I ran to Bahrain and to as I was at
the Jersey Shore for a summer and I got
that resignation so now I go back first
time in 14 years have you have you had
Springsteen on your show
uh I have had them on once Super Bowl
when he did halftime
Arizona Pittsburgh okay you never in
Tampa yeah had him on for about 15
minutes that's it
nobody else
and he's not a big Sports guy no lights
baseball though big baseball fan okay
but do you have a problem with he could
throw that speed Ball by you make you
look like a fool I mean speed boat yeah
Glory Days you know the speed ball
should be the club the basketball yeah
Stan you don't like it for knocking ah
yeah I listen is he gonna break down
like you and I
mean like the 27 Yankees but somebody's
got to say I mean nobody a speed ball is
what killed John Belushi like I don't
need that's not a baseball right uh it's
not a baseball reference yeah I guess
I'll give him a pass because it's part
of the song Fogerty center field yes
those those are those lyrics better a
little more baseball oriented I don't
even know no no Fogerty he loves
baseball he watches oh loves baseball
loves baseball watches it every night
yes he does oh he watches every night
yes he loves baseball by the way
there's one song that I can't stand that
Springsteen sings
what's that because I don't get people
excited over Hungry Heart when he's got
a wife and kids in Baltimore Jack and
then all of a sudden he leaves them and
people are you know they're having a
damn good time that he just left his his
wife and his kids Chris it's a good
point and that's a bit he does that song
and bought him all the time uh that was
if I'm not mistaken hungry to Heart it
might be one of his most best-selling
singles when that came out you know
whenever It Was 1980 81. uh did you see
him on this tour I did not
um are you going to see him I would like
to I just don't like the hassle of
getting to a show
pain in the neck yeah oh you got the
vegan Sun you got Albany he hasn't
played those two spots yet I want to go
see Taylor Swift before I want to see
spring I've seen I haven't seen her yet
either is she going to Boston uh I don't
know I haven't checked the schedule but
I've seen Bruce a few times and always
enjoyed it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah I saw him twice I saw him in
Boston and I saw him in New York on the
14th and I'll go again uh you know did
you hear him with Howard
uh yeah yeah I heard that interview and
you liked it I'm sure yeah yes yeah yeah
he did a good job yeah he did a good job
um yeah I will uh you know I've seen for
a third time I have my daughter went
potato Swift at the at MetLife yeah
loved it she went there and met life and
you heard about the issue this week in
Denver because she was there when the
Yankees were there the same weekend you
knew that right
who's having a better year though Taylor
or the Yankees obviously Taylor that's
right and the Yankees they can't lose
enough for me
uh Taylor was in Boston a couple of
months ago I'm being told so you missed
her yeah
you know that right yeah I don't know
why don't you go you like that why don't
you go it's a hassle you you know that
one Road in one room
watch golden Mohegan Sun yeah maybe why
not but he's gonna play hungry hard and
everybody's gonna be cheering he's
leaving his wife and kids they only
played hungry hard on this tour in
Baltimore it's been the same 27 songs
you will not hear that if that bothers
you so much it does and by the way
growing up and she's the one or my two
favorite Springsteen songs you'll get
she's the one he has not played growing
up yet
I saw him on Broadway when he did
Broadway
okay no he was not playing Rosalita in
Europe and he plays Rosalita in the
United States did you know that I did
not I did not know that yeah so that
seems that he has not played it in
Europe at all are you listed as a
Springsteen Insider uh I used to be more
stuff okay you know whenever I saw him
for the first time in 1978
um and I serve him twice that summer and
I took a blind date at Madison Square
Garden I got a lottery I got tickets for
the lottery so I saw him at the Garden
in August of 78 he played five nights I
saw him on a Saturday night it took the
Long Island Railroad in and I had a
blind date didn't imagine anything but I
went in and you know where he was on a
Monday night after he played four nights
the New Haven Coliseum
well he was an animal back then oh he
did I'll give you another one that's
funny I saw him one night in Lakeland
Florida
in February of 83. no I'm sorry 81.
you know where it was the night before
in Lakeland so he plays Lakeland like on
a Tuesday night on Monday night he was
in Starkville Mississippi not
Mississippi
that's pretty good oh you're great no
days off for Bruce I don't know no just
like you uh great to talk to you Chris
love you Danny thank you buddy that's
mad dog Russo joining us we'll take a
break best and worst right after this